>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT,
IT'S FRIDAY THAT MEANS
NOTABLE QUOTABLES.
>> I THINK I'M IN A
NIGHTMARE AND WAKE UP ONE
DAY AND EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO BE NORMAL.
>> LOOK AT ME.
I WANT TO BE THE LAST FATHER
OF A MURDERED KID.
>> THE MENTAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES FAILED.
>> THE SYSTEM FAILED.
>> FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
FAILED.
>> OUR PRESIDENT FAILED.
>> LESS TWEETING HERE, A
LITTLE MORE LISTENING.
>> I DIDN'T GET A LOT OF
PLAY IN YESTERDAY'S REALITY
TV GOVERNANCE MEETING.
>> I'M THE BIGGEST FAN OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
SOME OF YOU HAVE PEOPLE ARE
PETRIFIED OF THE NRA.
>> WE CALL IT THE
WHACK-A-MOLE GAME.
IT'S TIME FOR WHACK-A-MOLE
TO END.
>> PLAYS BOTH ARSONIST AND
FIREFIGHTER.
>> WHEN I SAY CALLS FOR END
OF OPERATIONS WE MEAN IT.
>> THEY DO NOT HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO OPEN THEIR
DOORS WHEN ICE OFFICIAL
KNOX.
>> I WILL SAY THIS TO THE
MAYOR AND EVERY OTHER
POLITICIAN THAT WANT TO
VILIFY THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
ICE.
WEAVER NOT GOING AWAY.
>> ANY TIME A SECURITY
CLEARANCE IS DOWNGRADED IT
SUGGESTIONS THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
>> NOTHING THAT HAS TAKEN
PLACE WILL EFFECT THE
VALUABLE WORK THAT JARED IS
DOING.
>> THE LAST THING I WANTED
TO DO WAS WALK AWAY FROM ONE
OF THE GREAT HONORS OF MY
LIFE, BEING THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, BUT I DID
SOMETHING WRONG AND GOD
PUNISHED OF ME I GUESS.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE I'M NOT
THE DEVIL.
AT LEAST MY WIFE AND MY